we're doing the book tour and all of a
sudden I get this email that the
Huffington Post is saying that George W
Bush plagiarized some of his book is he
talking about
because I knew that he and a former
speechwriter had worked on all of it
together
so I read it oh my gosh
so this reporter for Huffington Post
wrote that in Bob Woodward's book from
like three times three years ago there's
a passage in there in which Bob Woodward
quotes somebody who was a source close
to the president who said this about the
Iraq war and therefore they said that
that decision points that therefore he
was plagiarizing Bob Woodward and I was
like obviously he's the source close to
the president is the president you
dumbass sorry can we say that on here
[Music]
hey I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report reminder everybody get all our
videos and audio podcasts absolutely ad
free and early at Rubin report comm and
more importantly joining me today is the
host of the daily briefing on FOX News
Dana Perino finally welcome to the Rubin
report I'm glad to be here we've been
wanting to do this for a long time we
have been wanting to do we wanted to do
it in person which is why we never did
it via Skype but these freaking
pandemics is there is there anything
worse than a pandemic I mean it really
did get in the way of a lot of things it
really did so clearly you are you're not
in studio at the moment you are you are
at home and you've been you've been kind
of sharing you're trying to I think do
something similar than what - what I've
been trying to do just kind of like
share your life a little bit more your
dog what you're eating what you're
cooking all of that stuff in the midst
of this thing yeah how is life in the
midst of a pandemic well life is good
right like that we're here and that
we're busy and that we're working life
for me I have to say I just don't have
complaints or room to complain I live my
I try to live my life with a lot of
gratitude and then you go through
something like this where you see what
other people are going through sometimes
find myself kind of holding my breath
and I realize that it's because I'm
really worried about well people's
health number one but I also and work
all of these people who are now having
to ask for government assistance where
they never would have done that in their
life like they'd rather die than ask the
government for a dime and yet here the
government has had to force people to
not work and force them out of jobs and
now they're in a position of having to
apply for unemployment the government is
trying to be generous but it's also it's
the government and it's hard and it's
lumbering and it's just difficult and so
whereas things for us are pretty good
and actually I'm kind of needed this
forced pause because I was so
were scheduled and trying to please too
many people and doing too many events
and dinners and things so the fact that
I've had time to reconnect with my
husband and I've cooked more in three
weeks there's probably 22 years because
I like that you put the pictures you put
pictures even admitting some of these
things or experiments and they seem to
be working yeah I made I got I have a so
I have a peloton and one of my favorite
instructors is Hannah Marie Corbin and I
read an article where she talked about
what she eats in a day and she
recommended this cookbook called
oh she glows and it's a vegan cookbook
and I'm not a vegan grew up on a cattle
ranch so I'm not a vegan but I know I
need to eat more vegetables so I've been
making some recipes out of that book and
Peter likes them and I like them so I
made sweet potato enchiladas I felt like
a big accomplishment but Dana have you
taken my advice that I gave you on your
show last week and started growing
romaine out of the butts of other
romaine have you done that yet I have
thought about that so many times I am
going to try the butts of the romaine
the thing is okay so my day starts
before 6:00 a.m. and it ends at 9:00
p.m. so I've literally been housebound
for three weeks and my husband who
normally works from home he's done any
of the errands that we've had mostly
growing going to the tree store or
picking up from local restaurants that
we support so I haven't been able to get
the romaine butts but I'm going to but
you're going to alright fair enough so I
like that you said this thing about that
you needed sort of this unforced break
do you do you think a lot of people are
suddenly feeling that like just the way
life is and how fast everything seems to
move in social media and the 24-hour
news cycle that you're well aware of
that we suddenly got this break and of
course it's not for a good reason but
that but basically if you're okay right
now and you've got a roof over your head
and hopefully you have a couple bucks
that there really is an incredible
opportunity to kind of look at your life
and look at the world
a little bit differently absolutely if
you read any anyone saying like what
what do you really want in your life or
what it's that people feel over busy I
made a New Year's resolution that when
people said how are you doing
that's a couple years ago that I would
stop saying I'm so busy because
everybody is so busy everybody is trying
and striving and doing nobody says oh
I'm fine totally kicked back I get eight
hours of sleep a night everything's good
everybody has stuff so I stopped saying
that a couple of years ago and that was
a good sort of mental shift for me and I
but I know it in myself I have a very
hard time saying no to opportunities
that come my way everything is amazing
especially like in New York City would
you you know would you speak at this
event for this wonderful charity but
what about for this veterans group and I
I can be out weeknights every single
night of the week and then trying to
catch up on life on the weekends and
what I've realized is that you having to
tap the brakes because we have to all do
our part in this pandemic it's been it's
been actually really good for me and I
don't have I know that I can't hold on
to this completely when all of us return
to normal but I would like to figure out
a way that I could hold on to a little
bit of it because I I it is better for
me a lot better
yeah well it's interesting it's one of
the reasons why I like doing your show
because even though you're doing
informational stuff you're doing like
the daily grind political stuff like
there is this other feeling that I think
you have that a lot of shows kind of
miss which is that there's something
that's going on in the world at all
times that doesn't have to do with
politics exactly and I think for you
guys one of the cool things for me over
the last couple years as I've gotten to
know I would say you Greg Gutfeld who's
a good buddy of yours and Tucker Carlson
specifically it's like when we watch you
guys there's something a little bit
different about watching someone on
cable news then on the internet like
it's almost like are these people actual
humans and I think you've been able to
now show that window like oh there's a
human here here's the dog we're real
people that
he's been nice during this but you know
it's interesting I give Greg Gutfeld a
ton of credit for actually bringing me
along on that because we started the
five in July of 2011 and before that I'd
been the press secretary and that's a
pretty serious job and even though I was
in the public eye I didn't do a ton of
personal things like I would well we
didn't have Instagram or Twitter then so
I I didn't really share my life because
I thought who would care well then we
start doing the five and we would be
asked in what do you think about this
and almost always I was instinctively
giving the answer as if I was still the
White House press secretary for George W
Bush and at one point Greg said no what
do you think and it was about drug
legalization marijuana legalization I've
never smoked pot I'm not into it
I have a very unpopular opinion I don't
think it's good idea but I realized I
just froze and I had never given my
total opinion about anything out loud
and he pushed me a little and teased me
a little and made it okay for me to kind
of just more be myself and not have to
be the press secretary so much anymore
and so I get asked an interview
sometimes is there something that people
don't know about you nope like it's been
10 years we've been doing the 5 and I
was yeah there is pretty much nothing
people don't know about me so Greg
actually really helps with that and then
especially on the 5 we take our we take
the news seriously but we don't take
ourselves that seriously and life is
life can be sweet and God meant for us
to be joyous and I really learned that
from President George Bush too we worked
very hard but we were always separating
the joys of getting a chance to serve at
the highest levels of government for the
best country the world's ever seen
yeah so all right let's back up to that
for a second so for the people that
don't know you just reference but you
were press secretary for George W Bush
that means you're the person I remember
watching you back in the day this
ference yeah yeah your answer and you're
answering or at least to the best of the
ability of a press secretary answering a
lot of tough questions related to
foreign policy and the economy and all
kinds of stuff can you give me like some
insight into what that job was like then
versus maybe how it is now I mean Trump
barely has to use a secretary a press
secretary because he's just kind of out
there and and then the network's now CNN
doesn't even cover those things anymore
you guys cover it but how that sort of
has changed over you know it's been
about what 20 years or so 15 years if
it's interesting in January of 2009 so
January 20th 2009 the Bush's turn things
over to the Obamas I was there for the
last day and then Peter I left for
Africa we went to South Africa for two
weeks vacation in two weeks volunteering
at a PEPFAR site and I really I wanted
that time to reset my priorities reset
my marriage reset my brain and to get
ready for this transition but I think
back on that and I didn't even have a
Twitter account at that point and if you
think just that was 2009 think in 10
years how things change so dramatically
and you think about the Obama campaign
that absolutely smoked the Republicans
on social media in 2008 campaign and
then in 2016 president Trump realizes
that he can talk directly to people and
he was very comfortable with that I
don't know if George Bush ever would
sometimes I laugh and think about
writing a book of tweets Bush would have
sent but I am it has changed so much
like now I will say this I think for the
country briefings from the press
secretary I always tried to turn down
the temperature in the room I thought
why are we fighting I'm here to give
information you're here to elicit
information
I always remember too that those
reporters have a job to do and part of
my job as press secretary I believed was
protecting their right to have access to
the government and but here's the other
thing I
truly believe that a press briefing a
daily press briefing forces a White
House to have really good process
because if they know that the press
secretary is gonna have to go out there
and she's gonna have to answer all
answered these questions and that mean
you better her back first if there's
problems and the policy isn't settled
everybody needs to get on the phone and
get it done and thing I used to do was
let's say I was good we were at war when
I was press secretary so things are also
different but let's say something was
happening and it was a national security
issue and somebody within the government
suggested I say such-and-such answer at
the briefing well when I did because I
was a reporter by training is I would
double-check and triple-check so I had
my deputies and I would say Gordon can
you call the national security council
see if this is what they say Tony's
gonna call DoD you call the CIA let's
meet back here in 20 minutes and if
everybody has the same answer I'll say
it at the podium and if we don't then I
would go to the chief of staff's office
and I'd say we've got a problem here
because everybody's not settled and we
have to get this right because people's
lives are on the line so in that case I
feel like forcing good process is really
good but everything's changed so much
who knows if it'll ever go back to being
a daily press briefing no the president
well we just finished he does he does
some now I think we're starting to enjoy
it in the briefing room well he's having
a hell of a time and there clearly I
mean I it from the little bit that I can
you know I don't have time either to
watch these huge things in there talk
about they're in their totality but when
I watch them I'm like yeah he's actually
having fun but that sort of gets to what
I wanted to ask you about just sort of
the general way we talk about presidents
so it's like I remember during the Iraq
war and you being up there and all the
things I lived on the Upper West of New
York City the most liberal place on
earth and you know outside Zabar's
they'd have the book tables and every
book was george w bush is the devil and
evil and all of that stuff we're now the
media because he's not Trump they sort
of treat him like a nice guy he's also a
little older he paints now so
they he's kind of good now and Trump is
the ultimate evil do you see that sort
of always churning through like every
ten years where the media takes someone
they hate now they're good because they
have a new bad guy and that these pieces
will always sort of shift around I have
a great story for you about that Marlin
Fitzwater was the press secretary for
Ronald Reagan and George HW Bush so for
eight years he was a press secretary for
eight years I joke with him that's a
long but he told me that well actually I
invited him to my house in October of
2008 I invited all of my staff from the
press room I made them all read his book
one of the best books ever written in
Washington DC as a memoir is called
called a briefing by Marlin Fitzwater
it's fantastic his storytelling is
spectacular so he came and we had a
little book club and he delivered a
message to all of us and he said you
know I know you're feeling like your
boss is really being dragged through the
mud
our Preval ratings were terrible this is
right after the financial crisis as you
can imagine and he said let me tell you
a story about in 1992 and January 92
they had lost or 93 they had lost to
Bill Clinton and he said it was so
mortifying to lose to Bill Clinton and
he said when we left that day he said I
had my head was hanging so low because I
thought no one will ever ever understand
and see what a great man George HW Bush
was well he that changed you know time
it has a way of changing perspective and
43 used to say when I would prep him for
interviews toward the end I said sir
they're gonna ask you what you think
your legacy is going to be and he said
look you know last year I read three
books about George Washington and if
historians are still analyzing the first
president then the forty-third doesn't
have a lot to worry about
and she would point out that Abraham
Lincoln died thinking that the country
thought he was a failure so yes I think
that the fact that 43 could help me lift
my gaze from current crisis and current
feelings and lift my gaze and understand
there's a longer view and that really
helped me in my life actually overall
not just in politics yeah I love that
can you talk a little bit about just
generally what it's like sort of working
at Fox and being in the the eye of the
storm where often you guys are as
critiqued as the politicians you're
supposed to be talking about and I and
this is a particularly unique thing to
Fox where every given day we know that
Media Matters is watching you guys
waiting for you to stumble over some
word then they clip that video they get
it out to HuffPo they get it to box they
try you know they lie about timelines
Greg's dealing with a version of this
right now related to coronavirus how in
a weird way the stories then become
about you or that you know somebody's
boycotting Tucker on any given day just
that that whole thing so I have a ton of
respect for the media relations
department at pops News because they are
dealing with a they are drinking from a
firehose every single day and we have
strong personalities at the network and
we have the freedom to say what we want
to say I'm usually pretty left pretty
much left alone I guess maybe I don't
say anything that controversial or
interesting for for them to bother but I
don't like it when someone who is
expressing an opinion and then gets it
gets distorted I really can't stand that
and this is an example that I wanted to
mention it just came to mind it doesn't
have exactly to do with fox but it's a
good example of my experience of dealing
with the media and you mentioned the
Huffington Post so I did the PR for
george w bush's memoir decision points
when it came out in 2010 and we're out
there the book is launched going pretty
well although 43 boy he had not done
interviews in two years and he was
not excited to see the press again I'll
tell you that I bet what he really you
know often presidents disappear for a
little while but he sort of he really
just went under the radar finally there
was that picture of him painting oh what
happened yeah he said for a long time he
said I don't seek the klieg lights I
don't want this attention and he knew
that there was another chapter and that
he had watched his dad be such a
gracious former president and that's
that was his role model but back to the
book tour so we're doing the book tour
and all of a sudden I get this email
that the Huffington Post is saying that
george w bush plagiarized some of his
book talking about because i knew that
he and a former speechwriter had worked
on all of it together so i read it oh my
gosh so this reporter for Huffington
Post wrote that in Bob Woodward's book
from like three times three years ago
there's a passage in there in which Bob
Woodward quotes somebody who was a
source close to the president who said
this about the Iraq war and therefore
they said that that point that therefore
he was plagiarizing Bob Woodward and I
was like obviously he's the source close
to the president is the president you
dumbass sorry can you say that on here
hey you can say anything here come on
out okay remember how mad I was and it
just so happened that the publisher of
the book was also the publisher of
Arianna Huffington's books so I was
getting nowhere with the reporter to
take it down and so she said that she
would call and get her to handle it and
do you know they would not take it down
and so I'm not a stranger to this
behavior and how they treated him or
other conservatives or Trump now today
it's just it's unfortunate but you just
have to work around it yeah but it must
take a certain amount of your mental
stamina during the day right knowing
that these guys are watching you or even
when you're just talking on your show
and yeah yeah my
accidentally say ass and then you go I
said that the guy carrying the alligator
with his mouth taped in the convenience
store and it was during one more thing
and I said what an [ __ ] and and it
caused such an uproar but we turned it
into something funny and actually the
president of the company got a call from
his mom and she said please don't get
mad at Dana don't get her in any trouble
she didn't mean to sue it say it was an
accident and besides she was right the
guy was an [ __ ]
he was Florida they talked a little bit
about the a little bit about the the
general culture at Fox because you know
until I started going on a bunch of
these shows like a year ago
I don't know I probably thought whatever
may be the mainstream zeitgeist is but I
know that you know I've been doing your
show basically once a week for a while
now and I go on Greg and Tucker nobody
asks me anything you know the first few
times I went on Tucker they would say oh
do you have some ideas that you want to
talk about but now you guys invite me I
go on we don't discuss anything I know
that I could say anything in those few
minutes and you you may not agree with
me but you'd be okay with it and we can
joke around in the rest of it and people
always say to me well Dave why don't you
go on CNN and MSNBC and I'm like well
they don't invite me
it's a good yeah well well I guess
what's the point also nobody's watching
but but you know they don't invite me I
can't just show up that I actually have
a point if you see you're not going to
be allowed to just be yourself and
express your views and have that
respected yeah but but the meme would be
Oh Fox News is just pushing out talking
points to everybody but I just know it's
not true because you guys let me say
whatever I want
yeah I've been there since April of oh
nine I've never once been asked to say
something press a message anything and
this has never happened to me or to
anybody that I know and I think one of
the best things about box it's a culture
of respecting everybody as an individual
but working as a very close knit team
one thing that people might not know is
that Sean Hannity has been
the papa bear of so many careers at Fox
including mine when I first left the
White House you know he knew that I was
interested in doing a contributor work
or at least continuing to have it and
continuing to be a part of the
conversation and so he recommended me
and apparently Roger Ailes said
something like well why do we need
another Bush Republican we already have
Karl Rove and Sean said she's different
trust me
let me give her a shot and he started
inviting me on his show once a week and
eventually that's what led me to my
contract with Fox News and every step of
the way this man has been so encouraging
of me every step of the way when the
five started he could not have been more
excited for us when the daily briefing
started he also is so excited and when I
see him on occasion in the hallways now
he'll say I can't hear what you're
saying because your show is on during my
radio show but I had the closed caption
on and you look amazing your guests are
great and everything they're saying it's
like so encouraging it's um it's been
really rewarding in that regard and I
think of a lot of these people that I
work with is part of my extended family
I look forward to seeing them every day
and it's a it's a wonderful place to be
I'm glad you asked me about that cause I
don't always reflect on on how great it
is actually so the media has been
leveled what do you think Dana Perino
one of the things about this time is
I've realized that I can actually do
everything from home it's not ideal
television and putting on a television
show like the daily briefing or the five
that is a team sport and Fox is probably
the leanest company I've ever seen or
been a part of so there's not a lot of
spare capacity so everybody trying to do
things from remote it's difficult but we
have done it there's never been a moment
of dead air we are on air all the time
but this morning I did two podcasts one
by zoom one by Skype I have done my
shows from here that's what I do
oh I wrote an article for Fox News
calm about how boredom can actually lead
to great imaginations I don't know when
I was a kid I was out to be bored my
parents would say get outside and play
your excuse to be bored and if you look
at like some of these internet memes or
hilarious this guy and Pryor he worked
at the Justice Department for a while he
took the theme song of growing pains and
made a video with his family called
growing bored but it's to the same music
and with all the video it is so good and
it's amazing what people can do just
from home or you know that Alan Thicke
wrote did you know that Alan Thicke
wrote that himself and he also wrote the
theme song to facts of life and a couple
others I had no idea that's awesome I
loved it Axl I mean that's a great show
yeah it was a great show but what do you
think about this like just the generally
that now people can get their news from
a gajillion different things you know we
went from decades of 6:30 p.m. ABC CBS
my watch and you know yeah but then we
went from that then we had cable news
now we have cable channels that you know
proliferating and then there's also this
thing the podcast YouTube other world
and now everybody's competing with
everybody like do you find it hard to
figure out what is true through that
whole mess not really because I have
trusted sources that I check and I I'm a
I'm a pretty well-rounded news consumer
and I have a pretty strong sense of
what's real and what's not and I'm also
as I mentioned before I'm super cautious
with my words and cautious with saying
anything before I know for sure it's a
go I one of my great fears for the daily
briefing is being one of the first
people in broadcast news to put out one
of those deep fake videos thinking that
it's real so I think it's it's a time
where it's like crossing a river of
crocodiles every day and I don't know
how it's gonna shake out but I also
don't want to be somebody who longs for
the past I'm excited about all of the
great technologies and Fox I think has
been really smart in trying to figure
out a way to deliver product for our
consumers that are still cable
subscribers but also during this time of
coronavirus they took down the pay wall
for the Fox News app so anybody that
wants to watch Fox News can do it up and
then I think they can capture new
viewers whether that be on our Facebook
channel or I'm sorry the Facebook page
or the YouTube channel you know I
started this thing called story time
with Dana
right when the coronavirus started and
every day at 3:30 I read a book to kids
and I just started doing it on Facebook
live but Fox loved it so much that they
took it and now they have it on Fox
Nation which is a streaming service Fox
news.com the YouTube channel Facebook
and Twitter we get it all around so it's
a lot of experimentation and it'll be
fun to see where it all leads yeah so I
know you're not a spokesman for the
conservative movement as a whole but you
do you think conservatives maybe had
some branding issues over the years or I
think are actually I think actually are
melting away right now I mean I think
I'm probably evidence of it you know
when I go and you guys are all nice to
me and I can talk and debate and all
that good stuff but that for a long time
maybe just the word conservative it
sounds kind of stodgy and old and it's
like why would a young person want to be
conservative that that actually some of
that's actually changing right now
absolutely but it cut everything cycles
through the decades
you know National Review for me is my
dad I think was a subscriber since I was
a little kid I think he voted for
Goldwater I believe that's right and so
I cut I just grew up in that world on a
ranch and individual responsibilities
and states rights that was super
important to all of us but sure
certainly things have changed for
example I think conservatives for a long
time were considered people who were
against the gay rights movement who were
against gay marriage and over time and
not that long a time if you think about
any history of protect that melted away
and
so that I think allowed for people to
give conservatives I'm a different look
but part of that is what are you
comparing it to and if you are finding
that you are out of sorts with some of
the nonsense on the left then you might
take another look at conservatism and
you look at somebody like Dan Crenshaw
the congressman from Texas I did his
podcast this morning he's a younger
different kind of conservative and then
you see him on Saturday Night Live
responding with grace and humor to Pete
Davidson who had so you know casually
attacked him mocking his war injury
so there's a lot of great opportunity
for conservatives but you know it's a
it's a challenge especially in there's
all these different ways to communicate
now so how do you get to your ideas to
be persuasive for a larger amount of
people especially younger people that's
a challenge but I think it's I think
it's going better than some in the media
might think it is huh interesting
all right now I'm gonna ask you to put
the press secretary cap on so okay I'll
give you I'll give you two things here
one if you were Trump's press secretary
would you want more responsibility and
want him to rein it in a little bit a
little bit and to if you were Biden's
press secretary would you want him doing
these live streams that are in my humble
opinion coming off pretty terribly I
think if I were Trump's press secretary
the one thing I would not want to be is
blindsided and surprised and that's why
I would never be it's incredibly
difficult to think about knowing an
answer at 11 o'clock giving that answer
at 12 o'clock and having it undermined
at 12:06 p.m. but that is how he
operates for some some people love it
some people think it's horrible the
biting question is a little bit more
difficult I don't know what I would do
there in a real fix right now because
Joe Biden is now the presumptive nominee
he's gotten no bang for that but
after Bernie Sanders dropped out
everybody's sort of like yeah okay
then Biden says I'm gonna start my VP
search I'm like okay well there's about
ten women that you might consider so oh
well I mean people are just so zeroed in
on appropriately so the health of the
nation and the economic health of the
nation and I think that if Biden were to
come out and push too hard against
President Trump right now and criticize
the commander-in-chief in the time of a
major that's just a domestic crisis a
global crisis it would look like he was
rooting for failure for the country so
he's got to pick his spots very
carefully and sharply and I just don't
know if he's gonna be able to do that do
you sense though that some in the media
are rooting for the collapse of the
economy and just that they viewed this
as oh we we didn't get Trump on Russia
we didn't get Trump on Ukraine
impeachment I don't think so that this
you don't think so huh no I don't I I
don't I mean I consume a ton of news I'm
not naive to the biases but there's a
lot of problems out there I mean I just
like the Food lines it's just the video
you can see from overhead a three-mile
long car line to get food in Miami a six
mile on car line to get food in San
Antonio that those are just facts those
are those are happening and I don't
think that they root for the failure
they might root for President Trump to
lose but I don't think that they root
for failure for the people for people I
really don't yeah I hope you're right I
mean I see some people that are pretty
mainstream voices that it's almost like
they just want this thing to continue
well I mean that was like during that
financial crisis of 2008 right they were
like oh now but it was like well that if
you didn't shore up the banks and you
ended up with something worse than the
Great Depression what would have been
the better choice and again presidents
can't worry about that
president shrunk has to again lift his
gaze and not worry about the headline of
the day lift his gaze look out people
are going to judge this for a year
years and years forget about what
they're gonna say within the next 24
hours are you making the best decisions
with the information you have at the
time on behalf of the nation and can you
defend that decision then that's a
decision you should make you should
defend it as much as you can and promote
it whatever you need to do but I
wouldn't get so mired and oh they're
against me because I think self-pity in
politics is pretty pathetic and pitiful
and you just need to win that just have
to try harder to win the arguments it
just takes a lot more effort that's why
I always tell companies if you think
you're gonna have some problems always
hire somebody that's worked in
Republican politics or communications
because guaranteed they've had to work
harder they've been through it once or
twice yeah yeah do you think do you
think that Trump those sort of needs
that in a way like it's almost like him
and Jim Acosta are just like a match
made in hell sort of thing like CNN
needs it for eyeballs and Trump needs it
because that's like sort of what gives
him juice so there's a relationship yeah
yeah the symbiotic relationship they
feed off of each other but I was
watching a press conference recently and
I could I heard myself saying that's a
ridiculous question that's a dumb
question but look our founding fathers
were really really brilliant
and the first amendment was first for a
reason because it's most important so we
have to safeguard it and if they want to
ask stupid questions
that's so be it all right I got two more
for you and then I know you got to go do
the five because you do have it you do
have a day job too so one I've been
joking for about two years people always
say to me you know Dave do you want are
you are you gonna get into politics and
I always say no but if Ben Shapiro
becomes president I will be his press
secretary is that a crazy thing for me
to say do you think that's a crazy thing
I've never said this out loud but I told
Ben Shapiro if he becomes president I
would come be his chief of staff well I
would be thrilled to work with you so
maybe we are putting the pieces together
here
just to see you thought you were gonna
get out and they pull your right back
that's so funny I never said that out
loud that's true all right so that aside
now the really the most important thing
where is Jasper and tell us about Jasper
and let's see Jasper so Jasper is eight
years old he's here Jasper hey can you
come here come come Clyde Clyde always
gets shy when I'm on your show so let's
see if Jasper can show them up come on
since he was a kid's since he was born
come say hi to your people come on up
there we go there's a Jasper oh look at
this wait what come on look at Jasper
he's gorgeous he's eight years old come
on Clyde what are you doing come on
there we go all right know that dogs are
a great equalizer there's no politics at
the dog park for me we all love our dogs
and they gave us a lot of joy and you
know whatever love you give them you get
back five times in return I'm so so glad
that you two plunged back in and rescued
Clyde it makes me happy for you and your
household and for Clyde in particular
and I told you literally I had him like
it was like the second day I had him and
I'm walking him down the street and this
guy my neighbor for years who I've seen
for years but never said hello to who's
oh that's Clyde I just saw him on Dana
Perino show so we're making the world a
better place let me go I love that I
really know you yeah same here well
thanks for thanks for doing good work in
in the midst of this craziness and
showing people that you can be human and
still like politics and and taking good
care of Jasper so have a great day
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
chin Bell